nella trachea smaschera un de merda che
sta volevo introdurre il video di oggi
ragazzi visto che non sono a casa mia
quindi ho usato il telefono infatti c'è
un sound di merda si vede di merda me ne
vado a [ __ ] faccio prima mi dicono
che la sfida che avevo fatto con greta
per quanto riguarda social facebook come
quella sfida era troppo corta per valere
un video per che durava quattro minuti e
mezzo ho deciso questa volta di mettere
due sfide di social face quindi ragazzi
spero che vi piace vi lascio alle
challenge abbiamo qui sei tu
avete un minuto di tempo per indovinare
una parola che io e suri vi diremo il
primo che indovina si salva
l'altro becca una torta in faccia bene
chi prendi più torte in faccia
ok si parte 32 via del tuo sangue cosa
c'è il globo cosa ci sono le sangue
globuli non cazzo che ti aiutano contro
le malattie
ti devi protetti virus contro le malanno
di riprendere avanti durante anticorpi
non può essere sporcata gira allora c'è
un bisogno famosa pellicola alieni
colorati in un mondo vasto attacco
quella moda
cosa è successo
questo per attimo nuovo parlante davvero
un furgone eccolo buttate è proprio
miccoli fa schifo e troppo proprio no al
numero di cotanto vero siamo troppa che
abbiamo creato il macello dello schifo
questo tavolo è davvero uno scempio
leggermente schifo la panna ma poi
leggermente allora andiamo avanti
prossima quando uno porta qualcosa in
tavola d'avere in tavola insomma il nome
lo porta con la solita il cameriere
all'interno di consonante vassoio
partito vecchio cosa che gli empi
bicchiere che riteniamo
il ragazzo era nato un bambino cosa noi
di odio durante una frase cos'è che ci
metti in mezzo stesso
magari mette in mezzo una frase i primi
articoli più il sostantivo tra trovano
nell'altra partita la posizione siamo
siamo 3 a 2
sono calcolati col tempo e quanti
vogliono canta è nata intonato no cosa
canta canzoni non basta questo insieme
no
io io dichiaro
lo ha detto il vincitore
a caccia di un mio amico ma parla di
marcare basta questa notte e quindi
ragazzi questa era la prima challenge
spero vi sia piaciuta adesso passiamo a
quella dopo è sporca però se dello
scotch mi fate capire una cosa dobbiamo
fare una sorpresa siamo in mezzo alla
gente che cosa dobbiamo fare allora io
vi porto sulle giostre però in volevo
far rivelare prima cosa posizionatelo
che sono le giostre tu stai fermo qua
come bossi fumetti di così io posso
andare no no no no mi metti dietro
perché da che ormai faccenda
io direi di iniziare a camminare ma
mantiene sempre sua promessa e quindi
oggi io li porta le giostre ragazzi si
sta demolendo basta
lei non riesco a descritto non cosa dici
che la penitenza l'avete superarlo
a cacciare
ma come se ci libera la cura e quindi
ragazzi queste erano le 2 challenge di
oggi io abito a milano da solo ma quindi
la roba mela pulisco io ma immaginatevi
il vostro famiglia di tornare a casa con
la tuta lercia io quello buttata cazzola
voi mango come si apre la lavatrice però
che video vi sia piaciuto concluso qui
episodio fatemi sapere se volete altre
challenge niente dire che i like almeno
per la maglietta con buttato ci vogliono
anche a baciare i facebook e come noi
video totale descrizione sono riusciti
scalatrici che diamo così vito non c'è
il telecomando quindi devo improvvisare
da ragazzo si è rotto più o meno
su darmi i capelli così con la shell
io veramente sto usando la fotocamera
per asciugare i capelli perché non
andava al fondo in bagno mattino come
cazzo si fa a non far funzionare la
presa del bagno